so let's talk relationships for a second
let's talk relationships you get married
anytime soon buddy dude no
you're not kidding me i'm far from
getting you're far from getting you in a
relationship right now
no okay do you know the average cost of
a wedding these days average cost
average cost uh 50k 50k cut it in half
really average cost of a wedding in
america today is 25 000 here's a little
relationship advice for our friends at
home we got the you know i i say on
average our audience is somewhere
between
18 21 to you know 35 45 you know so so
people are either entering relationships
they're in relationships they're in
married or they're [ __ ] ready to get
out of a relationship because they've
been married for seven years average
divorce
anyway
um
average cost of a wedding so now that's
state depending there's certain states
where costs are going to be a lot
less you want to get married in alabama
mississippi it might cost you you know
10 15 grand you want to go married in
hawaii new york city california might
cost you 50. things but on average about
25 grand okay so here's a story about a
couple who basically had an option to
make
they were given to be going to be gifted
25 000
um
to spend on a wedding
or
they can take that money and put a down
payment on their home interesting
question i'd like to know from the
people at home
you get twenty five thousand dollar gift
you're in a relationship do you use that
on your wedding
or do you put that down as a down
payment on a home i'd love to get
people's respects about that i'm curious
what's out there so
twenty-five 000 is the average cost of a
wedding in america today you're putting
that
uh
into your relationship or you're putting
that into a home both are you know part
of your relationship
um here's a story you got this alex and
whitney morgan cute couple here they go
they had a 25 000 in a big decision to
make spend the money on their dream
wedding or a down payment on their first
home you know what they chose what's
that you know what they chose oh god
drum roll they chose the wedding oh
idiots
you idiots you idiots you stupid in love
idiots
here's their perspective and they said
they don't regret it they said they
don't care that you think they're an
idiot they don't regret it for them it
wasn't it was an investment
in our relationship oh my god versus an
investment on our financial future
okay
so here's what they said this particular
random couple the morgans i'm not even
sure if that's them right there right
there anyways they said for anyone
planning a wedding the morgans suggest
prioritizing expenses i actually agree
with them on that choose the aspects of
the wedding and that create and capture
the memorable moments so they you know
speaking of capturing the moments they
they said invest in a good photographer
don't cheap out on that invest in a good
band or dj yeah get that party hype and
those are the things they're gonna help
you to remember the days that come
so if you're gonna get this 25 000 and
you're going to spend it on a wedding
i'm cool
cool go for it 25 grand now really 50
grand
yeah i think a wedding can be special i
think it could be a down payment on a
home i mean our audience agrees with uh
myself you put a down payment hear me
out
25 000 isn't crazy that's not a lot to
spend on a wedding okay for for the rest
of your life you're gonna say i wanna
i wanna
i wanna remember this wedding okay 25
grand ain't that much you'll remember it
regardless of the price okay but some
people get opportunities that are a lot
bigger some people spend 50 grand on a
wedding right 100 grand on a wedding
some people you hear stories of hey i
will buy you a house or pay for your
wedding i'm talking wealthier people
right
when you start talking numbers like that
[ __ ] your wedding yeah okay okay go get
that house
because
you end up spending so much money
on things you know nicer flowers a
bigger band
um
nicer ornaments yeah you're part more
people on the plate it's at the end of
the day
i don't think it's worth it dude yeah if
you're gonna do a wedding look i've been
how many weddings have you been to
uh 10 weddings you've been at 10
weddings and you're 20 25. okay i am 40.
i've been to literally 100 weddings yeah
after a while they're all the [ __ ]
same man i mean i get they're special
for the people there
i've been to big weddings i've been to
small weddings and i've been to opulent
weddings and i've been to
nice weddings the end of the day you
just want to spend time with your family
and your friends yeah exactly that's it
more your friends
family is nice
um anyway that's my advice yeah
don't overdo it i agree man keep it
simple
you know the house
your financial future is probably just
as important but anyway
when it gets to started spending a
hundred grand 250 grand half a million
on a wedding dude i'd rather have a
house yeah okay by the way what's your
stance on prenups
get one get one you say get one but you
don't have any money right now yeah i
know i hope that the person i'm with
gets one because i'm not different
coming
anyway that that's a big question when
it comes to to weddings these days
because you never know who you're
marrying you know what the average
relationship uh lasts for the average
marriage
not long there's a reason that they call
it the seven year itch oh a little over
seven years get out of here yeah buddy
that's so interesting half of all half
of all marriages end in divorce yeah a
lot of them have been in seven years
those are marriages bro yeah now
relationships
99 of relationships don't work yeah how
many relationships have you before you
get married well that's the whole thing
nine ten before you get married yeah oh
yeah very few people marry their high
school sweetheart yeah all right maybe
it's five maybe 20 relationships work
anyway i see a lot of house emojis a lot
of housing yeah everyone else would buy
that house i agree get that house
person is gonna leave you they're gonna
hurt you they're gonna make you feel
like an idiot that house will be there
forever okay maybe not forever you're
not speaking from experience are you
a little salty right now
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke
[Music]